the Joe Rogan experience it's like you
what you said to me about wanting to be
makeup artist in reading those things I
know so many people like that you know
you know Danny Elfman with it was said
that to me oh really yeah
John Fogerty likes that yeah I don't
they wanted to be makeup risk but he
really likes like that stuff you know a
slash you know a lot of these a lot
easier different people and you know and
they went into rock and roll instead of
that you know and but you know I never
veered off that path I mean from from
age 10 this is what I wanted to do and I
didn't have a plan B and fortunately it
worked because I I grew up very lower
middle class and I wasn't anything
didn't know anybody in the film industry
you know and when I finally met somebody
I was 13 and Universal Studios just
started their tours and I talked my
parents they said you know you're going
to be a teenager it's a special birthday
you know what can we do you know and I
said can we go to Universal on the
universal tour you know and in my head I
was gonna hop off the tram and run into
the makeup department and they were
gonna hire me you know but on the way I
knew that are you familiar with Don
Post's masks the dump Oh studios they
did the universal classic monster masks
they were in the back of Famous Monsters
and stuff okay but they did these really
high-quality masks that were like $35 in
the 60s which was way beyond anything I
could ever afford but everybody every
kid monster kid coveted with those masks
you know and he his studio was in
Burbank near Universal and I had seen
him on TV talking about how he was
biting Universal so long he got close I
asked my dad if he could maybe look in
the phone book and maybe call up Don
post and we could go a visit and they
were very gracious you know my dad said
you know my son Ricky likes monsters he
makes masks and close by can you come by
and they said sure you know gave me the
whole tour Wow
yeah and on the wall in Don post Studios
was a picture of Bob Burns who I had
read about in my monster magazine see
he's a collector and he's done some
makeup he had a mummy suit and a gorilla
suit that he made and
and had his phone number and I wrote it
down and I again been I was still pretty
shy and I got my dad to call this guy
who I read about in monster magazines
and he was the first guy I ever met in
any anywhere related to the industry and
again very Bob and Kathy you know
welcomed me into their home he told me
you know he showed me how to do a scar
on a cutout of Martin's wax and where to
get the stuff and Max Factor and and it
just was like one of the first people to
show me stuff and he worked at the local
CBS station that and introduced me to
the news the guy who did the news and
men the makeup artists pseudonym made up
the newscasters and he was like blown
away by the stuff that I did he goes I'm
gonna take you to the makeup Union and
it was like 15 at this point and so I
went to the makeup Union with a box full
of heads and masks and make pictures of
makeups I did again naive thinking that
they were gonna see start tomorrow job
and the business rep of the Union said
you know give up kid you're never gonna
get in you know that you have to be born
into the industry it was a real at that
doing at that time there was a lot of
nepotism I mean there's still dad to add
yeah but he says you know if you were
Westmore you know you would get a union
card with your birth certificate you
know old man but nobody knows you know
know anybody you're not getting he said
first of all you have to be 21 to serve
an apprenticeship Elvis 15 he said
there's gonna there's only a few
apprenticeships and they're gonna go to
a West more to a Bauer you know somebody
who was a named makeup artist over a
relative right and he also said the kind
of makeups that I wanted to do which
were monsters and weird stuff you see
those jobs are few and far between and
most of the time you're gonna be mopping
sweat off of some [ __ ] actress hmm and
it was kind of like trying to crush your
dreams well he kinda it kind of did but
it also was like you know what [ __ ] you
I'm gonna show you and and I did
definitely did I mean boy was he wrong
yeah
turned out to be the greatest of all
time yeah well I don't know about that I
think dick Smith is the greatest of all
time but well you have to think that
[Applause]